Facebook commerce with the increasing
commerce on the Internet it is obvious
that ecommerce is also moving into
Facebook in fact for years social
commerce has been an important word in
Mark Zuckerberg vocabulary enabling
people to open a shopfront in Facebook
and then linking it to their existing
online shop but the next step is to let
all these commerce take place in
Facebook and of course on the mobile on
top of that Facebook now features many
different ad types that shops can use to
promote their products linking back to
the online store now watch this space
we've only seen the tip of the iceberg
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to set up a Facebook shop connect
your Facebook shop with e-commerce sites
like Shopify create a Facebook catalogue
use Facebook dynamic ads to promote
specific products and promote your
Facebook shop
Facebook has many options for e-commerce
you can set up a shop on your Facebook
page and tailor it to your own products
these products can be presented on your
page and you can advertise for them as
well and you can also add a catalog to
your shop which gives you the
opportunity to promote and target your
products advertising more specifically
setting up your Facebook shop facebook
allows you to set up shop on your
Facebook page by doing this you can
promote your products on Facebook and
offer prices for your products you can
also add a shop now' button once people
click on the products it will take them
to their website where they can place
the order they want to buy directly into
the shopping trolly setting up a
facebook shop has many advantages
you don't need an existing catalogue so
you can add an unlimited number of
products you want to feature in your
shop like any shopping catalog facebook
allows you to organize your products in
collections so people can easily find
the products
they are looking for and by activating
the messaging button people can ask
questions or even place an order to
create your Facebook shop you have to
add a shift tab here on the left side
menu now the way to do that is to go to
the settings and then in the settings
you click on the template and steps and
then here you see you currently haven't
got the shot as a tab so you click add
tap and that's where you have shop so
you simply click add tap and that means
your shop has been added and then you
can drag the shop to a higher level in
the tab menu
and then you can go to the settings of
the shop where you can switch it on and
off and where you can also copy the URL
of the shop but the main settings of the
shop are also within the tap when you
are on your page so now that we've
installed the tat for shop you now see
on your home page of your Facebook page
you here see as the third item the shop
click on the shop and the first thing
obviously you need to do is to agree to
the terms and conditions for your shop
you click continue and then you're
basically going to set up all the
details in your shop now the first
question you need to answer yourself is
how do you want people to buy the
products from your shop they can either
send you a message to buy you can
activate that or you can drive them to
your website for instance where you have
your online shop you can just get them
to the link of that particular page so
for this demo sake let's click message
to buy and we'll click on continue you
select a currency and then you click
Save and you're getting to the next
screen of your shop setup where you're
going to add products and you can also
add the description of what you sell so
when I click here on describe what
simply business sells I have 200
characters to describe what my business
does so I can just add for instance for
the demo sake social media training
products and services and I click Save
Changes and then I'm going to add
products so if I click on add product
you're going to add visuals for your
products you can add a video of your
product you can add name the price
whether the product is on sale a
description of the product whether you
want to share this product on your
Facebook page you can give inventory
information different options about your
product like sizes and colors and how
you want it to show up on your page and
who do you want to be able to see the
product so let's add some products
so here we're going to go to the photos
that were dragging from the desktop so
let's say that is product one and we're
going to use that this is social media
book and the price is 10 pounds and the
description how to attract date and love
your customers on social media
um this couldn't leave these as standard
options and I click Save and now we have
my first product added and I can add
more products see you see how the
product features in the product list I
can add my next product and add a photo
selective files here I'm going to
product number two and this is social
media training and we'll say that is 50
pounds description intro duction to
social media keeping those setting
standards that's product two and then
I'm going to add product 3 product 3 is
let's say a LinkedIn training and I'm
going to say again LinkedIn training the
price is 50 pounds
I'm clicking Save and then the fourth
product that I will be adding this
product for and that would be the
Facebook training
and that would be let's say 50 pounds as
well in row reduction to Facebook and
I'm clicking safe yeah for now they will
refresh of the page you will see that
all the products show up now there is
another area where you can actually put
products in different collections so for
instance if I want to do the Facebook
training and the LinkedIn training in a
collection I can then click here at
collection yeah so these are the
products that are currently in the
catalogue but if I'm going to add a
collection I'm gonna say training
products yep and then I can add the
products to the collection the one I
wanted was Facebook training and
LinkedIn training I've now added two
products to this collection and I can
then click Save and if I now go back to
my shop so let's go to the page and I'll
go to the shop you now see that I have
two collections that I can sort of scan
and browse through and I have my
different products so I can now start
promoting my shop through Facebook
advertising or by sharing particular
products for my shop on my timeline here
you see an example of a Facebook shop
you can see the desktop and the mobile
version of it on the desktop you can see
the shop tap on the left you can decide
what position the shop takes in the tap
listing you can do this in the settings
and you can see the products by category
and also you see the shop now' button
and the send message on the mobile you
can show the product specs a photo the
price to details and the link to the
website in the shop setup you can manage
all aspects of running your facebook
shop you can add products you can add
collections you can get an overview of
the orders and the pen
in orders the Facebook shop also allows
you to tag products you can tag up to 30
products and links in your shop you tag
these in your page posts when people see
your product tags in your posts they can
then click on the tag to shop for the
tagged product finally it is important
to connect your Facebook page with a
payment engine you can set up your
payment within your Facebook page so
people can buy your products directly on
your page but this only works in the
u.s. for those shops outside to us you
need to integrate your Facebook shop
with e-commerce platforms like Shopify
fortunately many online store builders
who have e-commerce engines can
integrate your existing products on
their store with your Facebook page this
means that you can connect your existing
online shop with Facebook and your
existing products will automatically be
uploaded in your new Facebook shop
creating your Facebook catalogue to
expand the capabilities of your Facebook
shop you should use or set up a Facebook
catalog consider this catalog as a
folder with all the products you want to
promote and advertise once you've set up
your Facebook catalog you can target
people with specific product ads based
on their browsing behavior in your shop
for example when somebody clicked on a
specific product in your shop you can
target them with an ad for that product
the next time they are on Facebook
now that your shop is ready you can
target people who visit your shop or
your online shop on your website through
setting up a Facebook catalog now in
order to set up a Facebook catalog you
have to be in the ads manager and when
you click here on the ads manager you go
down on their assets and that's where
you see catalogs because we've created
the catalog when we set up our shop it
will automatically show up here in your
list of catalogs and when you click on
the catalog you get to the screen where
you can select different type of ads
that you want to run for the particular
products you can see what products do we
have in our catalog what product sets do
we have in our catalog and what are the
data sources for the catalog that were
using and there is the settings for your
catalog as well like what's the name of
your catalog or notification settings
etc so back to the Diagnostics area of
your catalog this is where you are going
to decide what type of ad you're going
to use for your catalog so you can have
generic ads or you can have dynamic ads
generic ads is basically when you can
feature an ad for a specific product in
your catalog or when you do a dynamic ad
you can actually retarget people who see
specific products on your website and
they can then receive an ad with that
particular product that they saw on your
website but then on their Facebook just
as a little reminder that may push them
to buy the product so if I click on the
ad to drive traffic it will ask you
which accounts do you want to use and
then it takes you to the ad manager
where you go through the standard
process of your campaign settings your
ad account settings your ad set and the
creation of the ad itself now I'm not
going to show you all the details of how
to create an ad we've done that in other
demos but in very important section
that you have here is that you can
create an instant experience which is a
much more multimedia type ad that you
can select within your catalog for
instance you can set which products do
we want to select for the ads how do you
want to order the products like
dynamically or you can even specify in
order
are there specific sort of collections
that you want to use for this ad we do
you want to use a cover video or a cover
image and then what is the
call-to-action button that you want on
your ad and once you're done with that
you're going back into the ad set
creation where you are looking into the
traffic for the ad and be all the in
segmentation and then you follow the
process of developing your ad using
Facebook dynamic ads here are a few more
details about the Facebook dynamic ads
they promote products from your catalog
to people who are more likely to respond
to them because they have seen that
particular product before in your shop
or in your app or they have shown an
interest in the category for instance if
people are browsing hotels on your
website but don't make a reservation you
can then target them with specific
product ads from your catalog based on
their travel preferences finally it is
important that you promote your Facebook
shop there are many ways you can do that
you can promote your products by making
them stand out through videos and really
good photography and another effective
way of promoting your shop is by
enabling ratings and reviews often
people look at customer reviews before
making a buying decision and if you have
a physical store it will also help if
you add all your shop details like the
address and the opening times and it
goes without saying that when people
message you with questions or even an
order
make sure you respond instantly so what
did we learn in this lesson setting up a
facebook shop will enable you to list
and promote products you sell you can
even connect your shop with ecommerce
sites like Shopify you can set up a
Facebook catalog that holds
all the items you want to promote across
all of Facebook social media platforms
and Facebook dynamic ads automatically
promote products to people who have
expressed interest on your website or in
your app three simple elements for
promoting your shop respond quickly to
messages from customers encourage people
to leave reviews and add the address of
your physical store hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple
learning YouTube channel and click here
to watch similar videos to nerd up and
get certified click here